ότι ότι ότι ξπά πυ αέρκαε ο κι και παραβάνω ότι η ευχαίρει αναχειριστείς κάποια
πράγμα όταν είναι π άχει ερκασού τρόες μόνο το κόστος καιία τα πράματα τα οποία
μπορείτ να κάμεις θεωρώ ότιτα περίος δύσκολι τα ξσον και λες δύσκολες είχαμε ποβλήματα με
έργαδομένα α θεωρώ ότι έτσι πιο έντον και δύσκολαι ήταν τούτι περίοσκέφτηκε ι την περιόδο
ότι τούτων των αβάγειω μπορείνα ήταν να βάγειων και για την προεκλοκήουντάξειπροσπαθήσαα να έκουμεταλευτούν του
το θέμα αλλά ήταν τος εβαθικές ιρίε ήταν τόσο το θεμαγνωστνει τον κόσμο των πολή
ότι εννενοπύρας που ότι οπίρασε έκανε ότι παίρνα ποχειριντούκαι φάνηκε κει όστις εκλογες του το
πράγμα που ότι θα ότι είχα νιαν ότι να με επηρεάσει α από ψέματα ν
πό ότι εν είχα κι να εμεπηράσει αλλά ωσ το βαθμό των οποίο όπως ήν
τοκλίμα να αλλάξιεις για να χάσιος δεκλοες ένα πραθε πο θυμόν τι απάντα στους πολίτες
ου συχνά πικνά στα σόσ αλμύτια βάλουν ίδικά ο τελευταίο διάστημα για τα πολλά έργα
πό ι εξέλιξη και ότι πάλεκτυεται ότι χειρματικός κόσμος στα καταστήματα ότι διανίου μια περίοδον
που τους θυμίζει περίοδον κορονογιού έγραφαν κάποιοι πρόσφστασοςότιλαμβάνεστε ότιμια πρόκληση ήταν τον το μεγάλον έργο
στων μπορικόν και έντρον τις πους δέκα εφτά εκατομύρ να έργν το οίον εγώθερο απαραίτητο
ένα έργον το οποίο ι δικαστηματά ρχεσ δεγινη θα έχου ποιόσο αγαρά προβλήματα από ότι
τώρα φυσικά κατανωνώντα και καταλαβαίνοντας τον κόσμο λαδί ο άρνος που τα πάρεεγα πάρει να
ψουμείς πριν του ε ο εργοτάξειεντα χόματα δίπρα του ενκιάδικό τον κόσμο ούτε εθορώ ότη
ναάδικος ο κόσμος και ότι εναδικά που φωνάζε ππρ άνθρωπο να καταλαβαίννιστουν το θύμα αλλά
ταν εσε ήμαρχος κάποιος φοροιασφύγκης το στομάχι σου και να κάνουι καινο που πρέπει να
κάμνης αφοάσει επηρεάζεσαι σε μεγάλον βαθμόν που τις αρκαι παράπαρο δεν αδικό τον κόσμο να
μεφανει ότι λέ όι ναδικολογιος ο κόσος τώ ότε καλύττρα μεκαμίουν τη τούα ιδήμαρχος οίος
δεν περν